[Music]  - dude gotcha it's fun to be scared  sometimes huh  it's bet it's just a dog it's a pretty  violent I understand that some of youth  behaviors would be upsetting but I urge  you to find a place where he feels safe  I think it will be good for him good for  all of us  oh my goodness like that I must be the  very nice dude  [Music]  it's like he was broken before and put  back together who's this handsome chap  Brahms  how'd you come up with that he tells me  all sorts of things okay  I just think it's all a little bit  creepy  is this your new friend Brahms  what are some of the things you talk  about the other families he's Lovelace  take the doll away from him yes it's  just always that first something is  happening to him you your boy would find  it louia mommy I love you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]